i do want to ask you about working with
robin williams who
of course is an industry icon so looking
back is there anything
about your time with him that you catch
yourself referring to
today yeah i do um also it was robin's
birthday just a couple days ago
birthday robin um one of the things that
like
i was so taken aback by with him was how
willing he was to try anything the
director asked him to try
and what was amazing was he was doing it
in front of all of us because that's how
theater works right you're
you're not in in film and television
like you could be in a movie with
an actor you never even meet if you
don't have scenes with them
and you kind of do a lot of your work on
your own but in the theater it's right
out there in the open and i was so
amazed by how egoless he was about his
process
it doesn't mean that like i mean he
might try something and then be like i
don't know if that worked but he would
always try and i have seen
especially because like i said i i am i
also graduated with a directing major so
i had assistant directed a bunch of
theater early on in my career and
i would see sometimes actors like
sabotage directors choices
because they didn't want to do that
choice so they would like try it
but without full conviction but robin
would just
go like full force to try any way to get
to get into to get into the core of the
thing and also
beyond that had a work ethic that put
the rest of us to shame like he was
twice our age
and had ten times the amount of lines as
any of us like
he had these insanely long monologues
than this show
and he would show up like an hour before
anybody else to the theater
to like be running his lines and going
through them like going through his
blocking and
you know like he's a massive iconic
celebrity and not to say that that
excuses you from doing the real work but
the truth is like
there are plenty of like high profile
people who
i've you know not that i know of or
whatever like specific i'm not referring
to anyone specifically just like
that you know the rest they've kicked
their feet up after a certain amount of
time
and it felt like working with robin
williams was like
it was like there was no difference
between someone in the beginning of
their career the end of their career
like
he cared just as much and brought
so much of himself so i've always been
really inspired by that type of work
ethic and i
sometimes when i'm afraid of of a
director
of a direction i think of him of like
try it
just try it